the president taking the opportunity as
the vice president did to offer comfort
and support for these people here but
more than that they are very keen to see
what sort of Aid the president is
prepared to offer them we have seen the
world unite around not only Southeastern
turkey but also Northwestern Syria the
latest death toll has climbed well above
20 000.
us also at least twenty thousand were
told have been injured in the city that
I am in and in 1999 there was a previous
biggest earthquake here in this region
it measured
7.8 7.5 forgive me on the scale the
president just to head in this way now
and it's getting more and more bumpy I'm
going to try and have a quick word with
him as he comes this way for electricity
um
17 000 people died in 1999.
um as I said the death deal here has
increased to well over 20
000 and judging from the are you all
right then imagine are you okay you're
okay it's quite a scrum here now I'm
just trying to make room for this
elderly lady in front of me
you're live on Sky News we're
broadcasting around the world would you
what would you like to say to the people
who are supporting your country
hello president erdogan you're live on
Sky News
can I ask you what more support you need
for your people here in Southeastern
turkey
yeah
I think that's a no
um so we will try and listen to what he
has to say in his news conference I
don't know if you can um
come down to me so I did try and speak
to president erdogan I wasn't really
expecting a response but hey if you
don't try you don't get and wanted to
ask him about the support that has been
received
from around the world right at this
moment and want more sorry and what more
might be needed um for the people of
South Eastern Turkey we are going to
hear from him speaking in just a moment
or two and then in addition to that
we'll be taking you to the refugee camp
to see the sort of support that they
still need if you were with us this
morning you'll know that we were in a
makeshift Aid Center water had just
started to arrive there 20 000 people
relying on that Aid Center all the
infrastructure has gone here we're being
told that what they need more than
anything is shelter it is absolutely
freezing in the evenings here at Sam and
as a result
a lot of people are anxious at what's
going to happen next is that they will
die of cold I want to hear what the
president has to say I'm going to throw
back to you for now try and get in a
better position and come back to you
okay Burley they're in really the thick
of it amongst everyone there waiting uh
for some positive news the occurrence of
that positive news uh coming nowhere
near as thick and fast as of course they
would be hoping uh she's been trying to
speak to president erdogan there who was
making his way through the crowds he is
going to address people we will be
taking you to that as and when we can
but just uh a recap
uh here he is uh addressing
there in adiyaman
I'm not sure if we've got translation
on this yet but we will of course be
getting that translated so that we can
play it back to you but just a little
recap of uh what the toll has been from
that earthquake
foreign mine as if
more than 21
000 seven hundred okay we can translate
that for you we can translate that go
can you hear what is can we hear what
he's saying let's turn it up so that she
can hear it
buildings
we are very sorry foreign
I talked to the victims of the
earthquake
we are here
and afterwards I'm gonna go to malachia
my best Condos for my brothers
unfortunately
so that tall intended
is over 1900s 19 000.
at least 75
000 people
we have evacuated seven to six hundred
thousand people to other cities
foreign
inshallah
all the family members of the ones we
lost in an Earthquakes I'm talking all
the feminine to all the family members
who lost anyone in the earthquake
all the houses will be built up in one
hour
after the earthquake our government the
organized everything with all the
equipment teams rescues
we were we were on the area
10 cities and 500 kilometers area
where organizations
the problem with the organization was
that every Authority everywhere
and himself also affected by the
earthquake
so that they couldn't work
foreign
everything
of it will you see
all of our country all of our country
help is with these people in the
earthquake area and then only that's why
we said
we announced and state of emergency
noise is getting up
we declared a state of emergency because
uh there are a lot a lot of provocation
tips
no where the issue is
and to find the people who do harm
of course we have some difficulties and
negatives during this period
but you have to believe me that we are
beneath our victims
one of my minister
was
on the first day
another Minister
yeah
and they work together with the Mayors
and organizers everything here
John um
we will not allow any discrimination
we are very honest and telling the truth
is
civil or governmental rescue teams and
also some also International rescue
teams
are working on the area very hard
we have become 94 different countries
and the teams are still coming
the area affected by the earthquake is
so huge this could be done
on the area so the rescue teams
foreign
you know
I am assuring you that we all gonna
build up all the buildings in one year
we're gonna build everything give them
to their owners
foreign
in all of the area of earthquake
[Music]
despite the shock despite the fear of
the afternoon despite their loss
everything I'm very grateful for myself
to stand all together
hip
hop
one day
in our 20 years
we had the same thing in Elizabeth
[Music]
but we always held our problems
foreign
[Music]
is
Turkish Airlines
for everybody for going out of the
earthquake area or coming to the
earthquakes
foreign
[Music]
how come down
I'm working in this area
here in the old track area
do not allow any provocations
we have to stand together in such a
periods inshallah
foreign
there are bad people and talking bad
things about our nation and we will give
the right answer to them uh when it's
time
now from all over the country and all
over the world we are becoming We are
Becoming donations and humanitarian age
we are very thankful for this yes
foreign
all the donations
I'm only the translator I'm giving the
microwave
telling about it
speak to his people here are gathered at
the sports arena at the University
um
he says that amongst other things that
he has been telling us oh let me just
show these pictures live pictures from
eastendian I think someone can describe
the pictures to me
it's a rescue operation that is going on
as we speak
they are still pulling people out of
that Rubble alive
could do ghosts okay let's replay those
pictures for you should we this is
stencion
um this is someone being structured from
the rubble they've been under that
Rubble since the early hours of Monday
morning four o'clock in the morning just
after when the first earthquake struck
I'm just going to pause so you can look
at these images in a bit more detail
that's uh Rubble I can just see some
images now actually uh the uh yellow and
blue helmets will be the official
recovery teams
waving to the crowd and illustrating
that this person is still alive at the
golden time for earthquake survival is
long since gone now but on occasion we
are still seeing these images where
people are being brought alive from the
remains of what was once their homes
most people would have been sleeping
when this earthquake hits at about just
after four o'clock as I was saying in
the morning waving at the crowd to say
he's he's fine he's doing okay
many had thought it was turning into
a recovery operation but not for this
man he lives to fight another day
is with me um honey this I mean Mike is
thanking The Rescuers who managed to
pull him alive out of this Rubble
Goodness Me we're not expecting this at
this late stage are we
can you still hear me
yeah I can hear you now
yeah I was just asking you about the
fact that we have seen uh this man being
pulled alive from uh the rubble of what
was once his home
um and you know given that it's now
almost five days since the earthquake
struck very very unusual for this to
happen
yeah so I I can I can say the
devastation is beyond words virtually
every village in Northwest Syria and
every life has been impacted
I'm and I'm sadly confirmed that three
of our staff have passed away uh
during the the previous five days
I'm not sure if we have lost your uh
commas at the moment so as we continue
to look at these images
oh can still see um can still hear you
sorry I lost you for just a moment so do
carry on
so I was saying that Devastation is
beyond words virtually every village in
Northwest Syria and every city in South
Turkey have been damaged every life have
been impacted
[Applause]
can you hear me listen to the Apollos is
this yes I can hear you please do carry
on we can hear you there's no need to
pause we are very interested in what
you're saying so do carry on
okay so across Syria traumatized
families have been spending over over 50
hours out in the freezing cold as they
they are afraid to stay in building that
are under the risk of collapsing the
death toll Rises by a minute we are in a
Race Against Time to find survivors
provide warm food shelter and and
Medical Aid so actually till the moment
thankfully we the the rescue mission is
still going on and we we the the rescue
teams are able to find more survivors
yeah and as we're speaking to you sir
I'm being told uh by the team that a
second person a second person has been
pulled alive from the wreckage of this
apartment building almost unbelievable
more cheers
more celebrations from those that have
been digging for days and days to try to
find anybody that may still be trapped
beneath these mounds of rubble
um
we have stood next to
um several collapsed buildings over the
last few days sadly the rescue workers
despite their best efforts have not been
rewarded by scenes like this but
thankfully another it looks like a lady
this time has been brought out of this
wreckage alive I was speaking to the
former UK turkey ambassador to the UK
earlier on today and he was saying
what's most needed now is not food or
water but protection from the elements
would you agree with that
I do agree with that I do I do really
agree with that and this is the context
of turkey but we have to also consider
the situation of Northwest Syria where
people are really devastated and they
are really in need of basic needs food
items NFI uh Medical Aid that's totally
different context that the country have
been devastated with the with the 12
Years War and and all the all all of the
infrastructure was already destroyed
within the 12 years of war
um indeed so and we have even heard uh
stories that a town just outside of
Aleppo shortly after just a few hours
after the earthquake struck was bombed
by the um Assad government these poor
people
I wonder if you have a few on that sir
sorry
yeah I was asking you about the fact
that a town just north of Aleppo was
bombed by the Assad regime just shortly
after the first earthquake I wondered if
you had a view on that
I have no idea about it though
okay
um we must leave it there for now but
thank you so much for taking the time to
join us thank you thank you huge
surprise within the last few hours as
you continue to look at these images I
can tell you that president erdram has
arrived here
and Ariana was not expected at all he
has arrived at the university the sports
arena at the university did try and
Shout a question or two to him not
particularly interested in speaking to
Foreign Press but he did make his way
having
um spent some time with those that have
been struggling so much as a result of
this devastating earthquake more than 21
000 people now having died he took time
to speak and to comfort a grieving woman
he went into one of the tents here that
are housing up to three families up to
25 people expected to share a tent at
least for now he came out went to the
podium and addressed that he said we'll
we will rebuild this city if there are
buildings left in the city the
government will pay for People's rent
for a year until their new homes are
built for them in our 20 years
government we know what we've been going
through we've had the same before we've
had a lot of disasters in the past but
we always held our promises is what
president erdogan said to the people
here and The Wider world of course there
are elections coming up in May although
there is a three-month state of
emergency which will take us to more or
less the date of the election he said
buildings will be rebuilt as soon as
possible right across adeyaman he said
hey if citizens want to stay in a hotel
we can arrange that seeing the
devastation and destruction that we've
witnessed over the last few days I would
be surprised if that was an option for
so many of the people here lots of
people here are living in their cars
living on the streets or indeed living
in these tented communities or in
containers that have been brought down
to the area
um
helicopters heavy lifting equipment he
said are also being used to help the
people here he talked about the size of
the area that has been affected by the
earthquake in Turkey we're talking about
not in Syria which equates if I could do
this for you to about the size of the
United Kingdom he said we're providing
food for everyone victims workers we are
providing field kitchens and we've
certainly been witnessing that over the
last couple of days he talked about
Turkish Airlines he's saying they will
pay for enough flights for people to
evacuate the disaster zone areas for
free but what people need more than
anything at the moment is to be able to
have some Shelter From This Bitter
winter he talked about those who are
offering provocation he said We Stand
Together do not believe what they are
saying as we look at more rescue
pictures uh from earlier he says there
are bad people talking bad things about
our nation we'll give them the right
answer when it is time we're getting
donations and aid from all over the
world to that end that's certainly the
case more than 90 odd countries have
been offering support Azerbaijan uh
probably the biggest donator at this
stage Azerbaijan suffers uh with the
earthquake threats very often as well so
also very close
um politically to Turkey so they have
been offering significant support the UK
two we know initially that rescue
workers with dogs did come into the
region just pausing for the Applause
oh my God
these are the latest pictures from
iskendra where we saw two people pulled
alive within the last uh little while I
think we can hear latest pictures where
they're pausing for more sound
foreign
hoping that they may be able to hear
more people in the wreckage of that
apartment building it doesn't appear
that is the case though two people we
saw within the last few moments pulled
alive successfully from this building a
moment of joy and relief for the rescue
workers who've been working toiling for
hours and days to try to reach those
trapped under the rubble uh President
erdogan visiting uh here to see some of
those that have been successful in
getting out of their properties their
properties destroyed and are now living
in this tented Community here he said he
went on to say finally we're getting
donations and aid from all over the
world we are very thankful for this
we're trying to give a to whoever needs
it as far as president Assad is
concerned in Northwest Syria he has been
meeting people in hospital over the last
few hours we'll have a look at those
pictures for you as well as we continue
to see these live images from what's
left of this destroyed apartment block
this is in istrum these are live images
pausing again to see if they can hear
anything within the wreckage
okay
as people start to move around again
that would suggest from experience that
they are not hopeful the sounds that
they might have heard are indeed from
people within this building maybe a
creaking as it moves from to from side
to side Ezra is standing by for us on
the border I think you have some images
for us do you not
um of President Assad
this Convoy behind us that is now being
allowed to enter rebel-held Syria in the
Northwest is one of the first convoys
with specifically focused earthquake
relief items now this is not happening
in coordination with the Assad regime
this is happening in coordination with
the interim government operating in
Rebel Health areas opposition to Assad's
regime and this Convoy is from Kurdish
Iraq now we've been at this border for
the last two days speaking to people
eager to get in and help this is our
report
foreign
Volunteers in idlib are doing what they
can with what they have
cut off from the world and International
Rescue efforts
man begs the International Community to
help with a breaking voice
some of those who responded to us
yesterday are dead today he says
the site is just one of many in a
war-torn country further flattened by
these earthquakes
this volunteer says there are around 500
families buried under this Rubble women
and children and they don't know who is
dead and who is alive
blankets are used as body bags and this
small bundle carried out of the wreckage
tells the story of a tragic end to a
short life
but there are still Miracles at play
the newborn baby pulled out from under
collapsed building still attached to her
mother now has a name the doctors have
called her Aya it alludes to the sign of
a miracle a quranic revelation straight
from God
the first few trucks carrying Aid to
Sarah finally made it through the bab
and HOA border point
but many say that it's too little too
late
all other Crossings are currently
excluded from the United Nations
cross-border agreement with the Assad
regime
this is a border crossing into Northwest
Syria only an hour away from Aleppo over
the last 11 years of war it seemed
Millions pass through into turkey
seeking refuge and now many syrians are
moving back that way into the country to
help with rescue efforts
anxious like these men here anxious to
make it through and help
he tells me he sees no reason why the
world isn't rushing in to support Syria
I ask about the sanctions and they say
they shouldn't be enforced on the people
he points in the direction of turkey and
then back to the Border they're still
finding survivors what about us he says
there's no State there's nothing
as they wait to get in a truck goes back
and forth taking the bodies of syrians
home to be buried and then back into
turkey to retrieve some more
Sky News Killers turkey
so we have been here for the last two
days and we managed to speak to the
prime minister of Syria's interim
government that is in charge with with
the ruling rebel-held areas now he spoke
to us
and says that the Assad regime is an
opportunistic regime that they're
exploiting this crisis to hoard Aid and
that's exactly what we've seen over the
last cup a few days we've seen the Assad
regime ask that all Aid be funneled
through Damascus there's only one border
crossing that they currently are are
using with the UN Babel HOA to allow
through and now the interim government
under Abdul Rahman Mustafa is using this
border crossing to get Aiden from
Kurdish chirag and he told us that he
has Aid coming in from Saudi Arabia and
from Qatar that's expected to land in
gaziantep airport now we just saw Convoy
of earthquake specific relief items
finally make it through into Rebel
Health areas and the interim government
prime minister Abdul Rahman says that
the areas under his jurisdiction are the
ones that are most impacted and need the
most help from the International
Community
well this morning president Assad made
his first public appearance since the
earthquake four days ago he and his wife
asthma visited Aleppo University
Hospital to speak with people who had
been injured in the earthquake and these
were the images that we saw hundreds of
thousands of people and are homeless in
the middle of winter as a result of the
earthquake's tent cities springing up to
accommodate survivors and while some
indoor shelter is available few are
taking it up not just in Syria but also
on this side of the Border in
Southeastern turkey as well we were at
one of those centers earlier on today
Siobhan went inside the Sports Hall to
see what was happening
so we've come inside to the hall here
just to show you some of the areas where
people are sleeping some people still
actually asleep now and these are people
who've lost their homes really getting
what they can on makeshift mattresses
here but there is a big problem because
lots of people who've lost their homes
don't want to come in here and you can
see why you can see some of the bricks
here have fallen onto the floor and
people are concerned that they've
already survived two earthquakes and
they're really worried that if there was
another one that this whole building
could come down so some people just
aren't risking it and they're determined
to sleep elsewhere in their cars outside
or in tents
yeah and also uh they just can't go home
again in fact one lady that we spoke to
this morning uh when the earthquake
struck she wrapped her arms around her
children 90 seconds that Quake went on
for as soon as it stopped she ran out of
her apartment building and she realized
the keys to her car were still left
inside she went back leaving the
children with Neighbors in order to grab
the keys and she has been living in her
car ever since the heating is not
working in the vehicle and they are
desperate for help and support president
erdogan talking about that in his
broadcast just a few moments ago
suggesting that whoever does not have
accommodation will be able to rent
apartments or be able to stay in a hotel
having seen the devastation here in this
city 75 of it is damaged the other 25
percent completely destroyed so I'm not
sure where they're going to be staying
but the president is pretty confident
about that so let's wait and see how
that develops a lot of support from
overseas the president thanking people
right around the world for their help
and support UK Charities have launched
an appeal to raise urgent funds to help
people affected by the earthquakes the
disasters emergency committee's appeal
has received the backing of The Prince
and Princess of Wales and it's gained
the support of celebrities such as
continue the Big Challenge ahead is to
help the millions who have survived it
the humanitarian situation is expected
to get worse in the coming days
countless injured need vital medicine or
hospital care
and those now homeless face the freezing
winter without any shelter food or clean
water
whatever you can manage every penny will
make a difference
so please donate now
trauma cannot be undone but we can and
we must help
well if you would like to make a
difference to the lives of people here
and in Syria you can donate online at
dec.org.uk or by calling the 24-hour
donation line details are on your screen
and now we are being told that every
penny that is being donated will help
meanwhile thousands of thermal blankets
were sent to Turkey on an RAF transport
plane they were sent last night arrived
this morning the ministry of Defense has
also confirmed that the UK will provide
a field hospital and critical 24 7 care
and air support in the next few days
that means basically helicopters taking
people away from here to areas where
they can get more support and a reminder
you can watch a special documentary
disaster Zone the turkey Syria
earthquake half past nine tonight here
on Sky News